I think Nico
and us have talked about this in the
past Nico's not in favorite and I okay
face of extremum
I think we should do Facebook stream
Facebook's streaming yeah like you can
actually live stream from your phone
through Facebook the corridor Facebook
page has like 150,000 fans likes or
whatever and anytime we post something
it just goes straight to the feet yeah
it's cool but when you livestream it
actually sends a notification out to all
of the followers my suspicion is that a
live stream for just 10 minutes will be
way more successful than any post we've
ever made in that this this is what was
actually shown oh why do I don't think
we're gonna do Brazil dance card up
there are a lot of effects the idea is
that most of these shots are either
point tracks or object tracks Ren I
think building that grenade element for
now should probably be part number one
because that's going to determine how
good the track needs to be go amorphous
go blobby goes go for something that
doesn't require hard definition that the
rotos don't have to be hard
tracking they have to be hard member we
just have to suggest the idea of a
plasma grenade more than show a real
live class or innate I'm gonna go live
welcome to the corridor digital studio
no there's 12 viewers already 29 viewers
57 viewers oh man because watching right
now I didn't know this but apparently it
sends a notification to your phone that
we are streaming so 140,000 people just
got a facebook notification this is
sending out a note that means thing is
there's no more secrets anymore with
this live streaming feature okay tonight
connection oh okay I think we're back I
think we're back right it's still not
working
yeah everyone come close to the Wi-Fi
and warm up just gotta restart the app
apparently oh man
don't break the internet so we were
about to go up to the roof but we might
lose signal Nico is seeing everything
that the drone currently sees any time
we have a video where there's gonna be
like a lot of effects I will actually
make a spreadsheet so I'll usually like
collect several different effects and
put it into the same project file in
after-effects for instance at the
beginning of the video there's like this
big fight instead of making a separate
project file for each individual effect
amalgamate the effects together so that
you end up with the opening battle
project file and within that you'll have
six different effects I feel like we
always have this issue we have more
effects than days to do it we have a two
week schedule every two weeks a new
quarter digital video goes up which
means two weeks from yesterday and other
videos going up and that's this
masterchief video that we've not even
started the effects on which gives us
working days including today nine more
days remember sound with an item user so
carmichael brings up a very good point
as the sound designer we need more time
for sound design than you know zero time
realistically we have to add at least
two days for sound and music so VFX
needs to be done basically seven days
from now including today safety okay so
six regardless that doesn't make our
situation any better when you put it
like that
six days two artists 42 shots yeah got
it
I like your confidence in me better ask
somebody